je connaissais pas mais par contre je
cherche un coach sportif donc vous
pouvez pas nous faire une démonstration
des pompes sur une main bien sûr on
pense à une a bêtement alors moi rigoler
je veux bien mais je suis pété le poney
je comprends tout à fait chérie tu as
aussi c'est très simple on se met au sol
en promesses m'a dit tu prend l'espace à
grasse comme ceux ci a way up et voilà
en gros c'est beau mais on le voit le
chalet non mais c'est où il faut pas la
laisser tranquille paraît douter
prochaine qu'est ce qu'on y est arrivé
tout y arrivera alors pas tout le monde
aura tout ce que moi ça jure castaldi
voulait semaine
[Applaudissements]
regardez allez-y
ingénieur est au sol et pecs au sol
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
glacé et benjamin bratt la justice mais
qui va jouer comme je dis ou
alors qu latine
[Rires]
[Musique]